it's tv magic suddenly i'm on a red
carpet one-on-one with ryan reynolds
cheryl how are you good how are you like
in person oh boy that's a lot of
pressure cheryl i do not want to screw
this up for you
screw it up ryan you could never
bringing the star power to toronto we
reunite with ryan for his latest flick
the atom project i know that you
vacation hard as well so like this is a
big i'm on a vacation for you coming
into work i know
that's classified but yes
that once was
where are you going
what would you say to your younger self
that's sort of what we tackle in the
movie is that you think when i meet my
younger self i'm going to be this sweet
generous like caring person but i'm
actually just the opposite i'm a kind of
a to them
take it easy
or
you know fall down and scream so you
know if i saw my younger self i'd
probably be like hey you're going to be
like a certifiable [ __ ] until you're
about 35 years old but then you're going
to get it together
dad
dad
i remember one time you said you were
going to take a break you wanted to be
home with the family and to chill out so
is the reason the back-to-back movies
because blake wants you out of the house
no you know when we shoot something it's
a family affair we all go and this is
kind of what a sabbatical looks like for
me i'm not away shooting anywhere i'm
basically home every day i have a lot of
work to do but that work i get to do
from home so i get to walk the kids to
school and bring them home at night it's
just you know it's how it should be you
made me incredibly unpopular with my son
when i said no to deadpool so could you
tell jackson why i'm a good parent
you're probably thinking this was a
superhero movie but that guy in the suit
just turned that other guy into a kebab
jackson your mom is the greatest and you
know something what you're watching
tonight the adam project is kind of a
love letter to parents it seems like a
big time travel movie with a whole bunch
of science fiction and fun in it but
it's actually a trojan horse we're
smuggling a little love story to your
mom
[Music]